Brittney's little sister Jamie LAN is
stepping back into the spotlight after
taking time out as a team mom her new
singles sleepover just dropped today and
she has a special airing this Sunday on
TLC but tonight it's all about family as
we bring you part two up so we shall ace
these exclusive at home visit do you
before you see yourself having more kids
of course my husband would like kids
like yesterday right but for me I think
that um having children it's about
timing as well
well mama's got to work work work needs
making music and when it comes to stuff
to sing about well Jamie Lynn Spears has
already experienced more in her 25 years
than most people twice her age why do
you want to break up with me she was a
rising star on Nickelodeon with an
insanely popular big sister
and then jamie-lynns life changed in an
instant she was 16 and pregnant she
wrote a song about how she found out
it's about embracing your story and not
apologizing or being ashamed of it
because it makes you who you are as long
as you grow from it you don't have to
apologize for it Jamie spent the better
part of the next nine years out of the
spotlight but not anymore she's sharing
her life now on her TLC special how
scary was it to bring the cameras into
your life and especially with a young
daughter at home it was very scary I
think it's scary any time that you're
around cameras when I became pregnant
the world that I knew came crashing down
I look back down I'm like oh my gosh
Jamie told her mother the news and a
note what do you think are some of the
biggest misconceptions about Jamie Lynn
is there anything that you wish people
saw more of from her her funny side yeah
because she is so funny the way she
imitates people she's right on does she
do a good Britney impression no she
doesn't really good impression it would
happen
that should be a Saturday Night Live
thing this special also glimpses that
Jamie Lynn's life with her husband Jamie
her daughter Maddie stepfather what's
been the best thing for you about
watching Maddie grow up she's just a lot
of fun we like to like you know she's
whether it's she's not scared of life if
I'm doing it she can do it you know
anything we do she's all for it
so are you open to the idea of having
cameras as a regular part of your life
as now no but I'm so proud of it and
it's one of those things that I'm really
happy I did Never Say Never
right yeah you can't say never to
anything I've learned that lesson